and we can bring you some breaking news
now and that is both rishi sunak and liz
trust have agreed to take part in a sky
news live televised debate next month
our deputy political editor sam coats
joins us from central lobby in fact he
is in westminster
um
sam good evening so it's rishi sunak
versus liz truss and debate now debates
could be important in this contest
this debate will take place at a
critical point in the competition to be
the next prime minister rishi sunak and
liz trust have agreed to go head to head
at sky news in front of k burley and a
live studio audience at 8pm on thursday
august the 4th that is the week that
tory members the 160 170 000 people who
will determine britain's next prime
minister will be receiving their ballot
papers so the two figures at the heart
of this race appearing on sky news
debates being absolutely critical in
this race uh we've seen uh all the
figures clash over boris johnson his
record and the future they have turned
away this debate uh this leadership
contest uh from uh
all around through the last fortnight
and now sky news will be hosting uh a
debate at that absolutely critical
moment the week that the ballots go out
uh conservative activists will be
receiving both electronic and postal
votes
and they will be able to evaluate the
two candidates to be next prime minister
and next conservative party leader on
sky news